- [Nick Jonas] I brought you a gift.
- First of all,
you're invited anytime, you bring alcohol.
So wait, what is this?
Villa wine?
- So this is my new
tequila with John Varvatos.
- [Kelly] Dang!
- It started about two
and a half years ago.
We started a process of
working with Stoli Group
to develop our own tequila
and wanna have some?
- Um, can we try, I know
it's like, you know,
this show airs at like 9 AM,
I'm looking at your Nashville.
- Just a little bit.
- But yeah, I don't wanna be rude.
So let's do it, Nick, let's do it.
(audience laughter)
- Congrats to you.
- My mamma raised a polite
young lady, so I will drink your tequila.
- Sorry we don't have
enough for everybody, guys.
- I mean, fine, I guess we're
rationing it, but it's fine.
It's fine.
(audience laughter)
- Cheers.
(audience whoops and applause)
- That is good.
- Smooth, huh?
- It's so smooth.
I was a little nervous because
usually I do like a lime,
I mean, I don't drink ever but, um.
No, I do usually like salt and a lime.
That's really smooth.
- Yeah, we're excited about it.
So we just launched this
one on the East Coast
and the rest of the
country's kinda starting now,
but then we have reposado and anejo
as well that's coming out.
- I'm into it, so, okay,
let's celebrate real quick.
You want another one?
Okay, fine, I will.
Let's celebrate and drink to
your first season of The Voice.
You don't have to.
(audience laughs)
Be a better person than
me, I'm trying to be kind.
I just want to celebrate the fact that
you're going to be on The Voice,
and I'm going to kick your tail, oh!
- That's not true.
(audience laughs)
Incorrect.
(audience cheers)
I'm not going to clap for that.
- I'm not gonna clap for that.
I refuse to clap for that, man.
- It has been a good little
friendly competition so far though.
- It has!
- We've, you know, we've done the blinds,
which has been really
fun, my first ever, uh,
assembled a good team.
I feel confident about it.
- Yes, and we like a lot
of the same sound, yes?
- I didn't expect that.
- I did.
I thought John and I
would go head to head,
but it's really you and I.
- No, I knew it, I knew it.
And they, the guys, were talking about it.
I was like, "He's going to be...
"I'm going to have to
battle Nick fricking Jonas."
(audience laughs)
Like, what, I'm not going to win there.
I'm like a mom, like, so
not cool compared to you.
Like what?
So let's talk about it.
I know people probably ask all the time,
but I love Priyanka, and you know this--
- Me too!
She's so cool, but I didn't realize,
well, not really, I didn't
realize, like, how fast...
Well, okay, what was your first date like,
first of all?
- Well, it's kind of a long story.
- Okay.
- But I'll, I'll, I'll tell it.
- Synopsis.
- So basically we, um, we
were told by a mutual friend
that we should meet and he
said, "I'll connect you guys."
He never did and I got impatient,
so I direct messaged her on Twitter
- Get it!
- And she responded.
We talked on, you know,
back and forth about a year on texts.
And then we finally met in person,
and it wasn't, it wasn't really a date,
we just met in person
and went for a drink.
And then about a year later we went on
our first official date
to the Hollywood bowl
to go see the Beauty and the Beast Live.
- That's adorable!
- Uh, you know, just
recently we played there
to kind of end the first leg of the tour
and she sat two boxes away from where
we sat on her first
date, it was very cool.
- [Kelly] That's so cool.
So what I didn't know
though was y'all got,
y'all got married pretty quick.
Like people, I heard people kept going,
"Whoa, that's moving fast!"
First of all, stay in your lane.
- [Nick[ Exactly!
(audience laughs)
Mind your own business.
- Okay!
So mind yourself!
- I think, you know,
when you know, you know,
and we heard that pretty
much from everybody
once we told people we were engaged.
Uh, but we don't, you know, it was,
it was kind of magical, you know,
just within, uh, eight, nine weeks
we were, you know, talking about marriage
and within 10, 11 weeks we were engaged.
- [Kelly] That's amazing!
- And we got married
in December last year.
So our one year's coming up on the first.
- That's so exciting.
Congratulations!
It's really very cool to find someone
you love like that to be your best friend.
It's so cool.
So I heard when I was doing the...
I was reading the pre-interview for this,
I had no idea that y'all
opened for me in 2005.
- [Nick] Well we did.
- Because I feel like
I just got really cool.
- No, well so, no one
cared about us in 2005.
We were just coming up and
basically to get other gigs,
we listed the other acts
that we'd 'opened up for',
but that really just meant that we were
on like the outside
stage in the parking lot
while you were playing for 40,000 people.
- Still, still the same.
- But you helped us get
a lot of gigs after that.
- Oh my gosh!
- So thank you, we owe you 20 percent.
(audience and Kelly laugh)
- So now you're on tour for real.
So tell us about Happiness Begins.
- Uh, yeah, so this has
been quite the crazy year
for the family.
Um, you know, just a year ago right now
we had just started recording music,
uh, together again and, um, you know,
looking a year later we're finishing up
the first leg of a crazy tour,
and, um, also the album,
you know, Happiness Begins.
But it all started with a documentary,
which we call Chasing Happiness,
which was kind of just to tell
our story of our childhood,
you know, our father was a pastor
and we had a pretty crazy
journey in the church
and then into our music career together.
And we had really no intention
of getting the band back together.
But after filming for a little while
and kind of healing some
of those family wounds
that were there from our
years of working together
in the past, we were able to look at this
with a fresh view and,
and really kind of all
in different ways find our happiness.
And so we, we went for it
and it's been an unforgettable year.
It's been really amazing.
- That's really cool.
Like, not only, I mean I get like the fans
are excited about it,
but it's way more cool
for you and your family.
Like that's a hard thing to, like,
I mean, that's my road family over there
and it's, it's hard to all
be together all the time,
especially when you're related.
I can't even imagine that.
So that's really cool that this ended.
- It's really special to
share that with family.
- If the documentary,
would you release it if
y'all wouldn't have gotten together?
- I think so, yeah.
I think, you know, we had
spent money making it,
so we probably...
(Kelly laughs)
- You're like, "Yep!"
- And I think it was an
important story to tell,
you know, and that was, kind of,
I think, the thing that
was, to us, so special
about it, is that there
was no intention to,
to come back and do this
again at the beginning.
But when we actually just sat
down and did the hard work
that, you know, most families have to do,
we all go through things
with the people we love,
and, uh, whether it's
the family you choose
or it's your blood.
- It's usually the ones
you love the most, yeah.
- Yeah, you gotta go through it.
And, and, um, and we did.
And, you know, we look
up at the other side
and we're all kind of in
the best place in our lives.
- I know, you're all
married now, like, yeah.
- All married.
Brother's got two kids
and it's a beautiful time.
And to have been able to go through that
with your family is,
is, I think we're all really grateful,
and aware of how unique it is,
and so it's just been special.
- So cool.
I will say you have, like,
um, the most famous family ever.
(laughs)
It's, like, looking at everyone
listed in your family tree,
I'm like, "Hey, well!"
Those kids are going to be, like,
they're not going to know what normal is.
- [Nick] They're going to have some
cool aunts and cool uncles.
- It's amazing, y'all
should have, you shouldn't,
but you should have a reality show.
I just want to see it.
I want to watch the dynamic of
all those famous people in one family.
That's insane.
- I think the band might break up again
if we had a reality show.
(audience and Kelly laugh)
- If cameras are there all
the time, no you won't.
You have to be on point.
Um, do you have a
favorite song on the tour?
- Uh, I, I, I have a few that I love.
It's like picking a favorite kid, I guess.
I can't pick one.
- There are different vibes.
- They're so connected
to my songwriting too
that's hard to pick one.
Um, but we actually have just come out
with a Christmas song,
which has been a dream of ours forever.
- I love Christmas.
- Me too, it's my favorite.
- Wait, y'all don't
have a Christmas album?
What's wrong with you
- We did an album back
in the day with Disney.
We did a few, just songs here and there,
but this is like our
first, kinda, real swing
at doing a Christmas song with
the same group of writers,
producers that we work
with the rest of our music.
- Oh my gosh!
Do a whole album.
I love Christmas music.
- As long as you come on and duet with us.
- I will sing with you,
unless you're just joking.
- You already sang with
John a couple of times.
- I did sing with John.
(Audience cheers)
I love, I love Christmas music.
I think it's so cool cause
you can get away with like
that cheesy good feeling.
- When do you start
playing Christmas music?
- Um, I actually started in,
and my staff will tell you,
I actually started, like, uh,
two months ago 'cause I was
wrapping presents in Montana,
we've a ranch there, and I was
wrapping Christmas presents.
- So two months ago, so like September?
- Yep.
- [Nick] Wow!
- Never too early.
(audience laughs)
Because I was wrapping Christmas presents;
November, December, are really busy.
So I was having to do
everything beforehand, and so--
- You did say you were
wrapping Christmas presents
months in advance.
- I was wrapping presents, yes.
- That's impressive.
- I do that.
- I start shopping three days before.
- Yeah, so does my husband,
which is why I do it.
(laughter)